Ha hahaha hahahaha hahAHAHAHAH
hahahhHAHAHHA!!
Hellooo Everybody, my name is Markiplier.
And, welcome to 'Think To Die'!
Now, this game just came out on Game Jolt
and I love games that test
the 'boundaries' of good taste!
Because this game *weird Mark noises*
The only way to progress is by finding a new and interesting way to kill yourself!
And that sounds horrible!
And yet here we are~!
So, let's begin this terrifying and horrible
adventure...eh...
With a new game~
Really? yup! *weird mark noises*
I'm glad you asked me cause I wasn't too sure.
But, now I'm pretty sure I wanna play this.
Okay~ so, the concept being
*Inhale*
It's a puzzle platformer
Where this poor 'schmuk'
Over here *inhale* has to go through
The world
*Then the silence came on*
In wonderful fashion
Jump, and then..
*PLOOP*
OHH!
Ahhh...
See?
That's the catch!
That's the caveat.
See! I can jump,
and that's a red herring.
But the REALLL objective
in all of this adventure is-
*Screams of impalement*
That...
It reminds me of this game made by Jamtb02
Where it was, um, you know
he's the guy that made the little elephant and achiev-
(Singing Mark) auhhh, I wasn't ready...
Okayyyyy
Left click..
Right..
Use mouse.
Keyboard.
to move
OKAY!
AUGHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
*death noises*
Nice!
Good one. 👍
But, uh, Jamtb02 is one of my favorite
Game Programmers.
A while back... I-I haven't checked up on the new stuff that he's made.
But, he's a very clever, uh,
programmer back in the day that made a lot of really interesting
and intricate games.
*death noises*
Alr- wait wha?
Oh..
Falling off the room restarts your level..
Okay!
*death noises can be heard across the whole nation.*
Great! :D
I got a comment though
that this game is really nicely designed! :D
Like,
*death noises again can be heard across the whole nation.*
OW!
MY FACE!  WHY DIDN'T YOU GIVE ME THE MIKMBESAD CHANCE TO LOOK AT THE ENVIRONMENT?!
Which is awfully nice.
Why is the background keep
Bounce-Bumpin?
Oh~ I know what to do.
Oh~ I know exactly what to do.
Oh, I don't know anything what to do.
eh
Can I double jump?
Yes I ca- oh wow.
That's weird.
Okay. So I gotta move this over here.
Get, get down!
What are you doing being 'sticky' on the other thing?!
*death noises*
AUGHHHHHH
MY FACE HOLE D;
So yeah.
He made a game called...
uh *markigiggles* I forgot what the game was called.
I-It was.. 'Achievement Unlocked' was one of them.
EEEEEEEEEEEEE
How do I?
I WANNA GIVE UP!
HOW DO I GIVE UP?!
(Opera Mark) Ohhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh!!
Okay~
I understand now! :D
It's got 'Pacman'-esque abilitaas. (he meant abilities)
OooOooo!
Ahhhh..
Okay!
Buttehns (he meant buttons)
Buttehns (he meant buttons again) do things and stuff.
eah
Imma
Then theres a
OoooOO! Dere he goes.
There's a funky wall jump-slash-double jump situation that I'm not understanding.
ohhhhHHH
I KNOW THIS ONE!
THIS WAS IN THE PREVIEW
AND WHAT DREW ME TO THIS GAME IN THE FIRST PLACE!
The imaginative ways with which you can
BASH YOUR OWN SKULL IN.
Woah...
*silence*
Well, alright then.
Ahhh...
Indeed!!
woOAH
Yes, okay, so how in the hell am I gonna get up there?
Well ain't this a conundrum...
Well, I can't--
I can't possibly do that...
*grumpy marki groan*
This is a conerndrum...
Well, how am I going to be able to get up--
Oh...
Shitty dicks...
Oh, this is gonna be interesting, isn't it?
Ah, man! I can't do the weird double jump thing!
The wall jump--
Double jump doodaddy dangle
Ugh, son of a tits.
This's gonna take some BRAIN POWER!
*Brain powers activating, please wait*
I'm too stupid.
How am, me do...
Oh!
Oh! I-it's, it's a gosh darn red herring, ain't it?
It's a--
It's a gosh dern red herr--
You don't need n--
oops.
You don't--
You don't neeeed none of that!
You don't need that.
That's a red herring.
'Cause you can get by...
with juuuuuust theeeeese!
And then, all you gots to do
I gotta push these like...
ABOOM!
See?! You didn't need it!
It was a red herring!
Imma smart, imaginative boy! :D
I know what I do!
So...
What do we do now?
Ah!
*Definitely not English*
Okay, that did a whole lot of dick.
So oooh maybe if we...
Aaah I know what we need to do
we need to
dammit I kerfumbled it!
'kay so what we need to do is to put this over he-are,
put this over
*sudden seal mating call*
over there
push this off deeaah
get this over.
du-dangit...
*pant*
grsh dangit get dis over ther- we go!
Get this over- GYAA!
Get this- noooOOOO don't do that!
get this over dyaaa (x2)
and BOOM
BAM
I'm kinda forgetting that in the end I'm dying in horrible ways.
What is this poor guys objective?
What even is this guy's face?
I can't even tell what he looks like.
Okay, so that goes over dere..
*Another inhale*
And der dis button do?
*exhale*
That!
Okay, so there gots to be-
ooOoo~ Hey.
Can you? Thank you.
Okay, so ther-
*Death noises*
OHHAHHH I DID-  I'M THE GREATEST! I FOUND A WAY TO BREAK THE GAME AND WIN~!
OH
Handy that!
So this doesnt seem to terribly complicated.
I mean, the other one was a lot more complicated than that.
Even though theres a way to exploit it and get around the mechanics
*Inhale*
OooOOoo
What are you gonna do to me? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Okay so, you gotta go there.
And what do you do?
ohhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh I see!
I seeee!
Okay so theres no way.
To do that quick enough.
That that's gonna be able to go.
The distance...
So we need to
*Mark's 'hmm'*
Ain't this a puzzle?
So what do we need to do?
eh
Okay
That doesn't help nobody.
But, that might?
So maybe...I can jump from here.
OWAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Almost...
*Manly screams*
Okay..
What if I...?
Heh
Heh!
Heh...
O-oh shit.
EH
Ok, almost there.
*frustrated Mark sounds*
AUGHHHHHHH GOT IT-(sounds more like markiplier mating call)
Oh, god dammit.
EUHH
Dere we go!
So then...
Drop that and...well...
*Noise of someone getting crushed*
YEAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAOHHHHHHHHHHH
OH
HAI!
*mumbles* Press 'C' or click the switch button...
*Death noises*
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
EVERYONE GETS TO JOIN IN ON THE PARTY!
OOOOOooOOOO
SO MUCH FUN!
CAN WE HAVE A MULTIPLAYER VERSION OF THIS?!
But, this does add interesting puzzle
dynamics to this.
So this means that there's a lot of different
ways, that this can go about...
Okay, so...
This button
oOoO dat
button dah dat
But, we need dat
Okay, so-
Ahh, I know what to do.
Okay, so...
HEHBIH
*Deathly cries*
AHHH NO!
YOU LEFT ME BEHIND!
Ahh jeez.
*Laughs*
This is a horrible game
Id isn't like
dawning on me in burst
PAHHHHHHHHHH
YOU GOT TRAPPED!
In another dimension
I-its kinda *laughs* dawning on me
in fits and burst *chuckles*
Like the main concept
of this game is pretty dang horrifying.
But, YEA! WE DID IT!
WE'RE A WINNER!
WE GET THE HIGHSCORE!
*sighs*
It's just a video game...
Okay, so.
Ahhh, m'kay.
So we gotta get away-
We gotta-
There's gotta be a way
we can jump on each others head...right?
Yeaaaaah
Whoop, noo...
You get over there.
Get over dere!
Oka- ula ale-loop!
ale-loop
woah, dere we go.
I should of- I should of moved.
I should of moved.
I should of moved...
Okay but, I know what to do
EH
UGH
YEA
GET OVER DERE
IT WILL BE GREAT!
Hoop
*Weird Mark noises*
C'mon stop!
What are you doing?
What are you even freaking-
What the fuck are you
The fucking yeah
WoooAHh
These controOols!
Eh!
Ok
*Screechs*
Oh, fig... NOEEEEH!
Oooh give me some figgy pudding!
Fuck
Yeah, ye- ye- fuck
Ki-kocken...
**markiplier mating call
Oh man sometimes when I'm pushing
RIGHHT
It goes, LEFFT
Thats what you call bad CONTROOOOLSS
*inhales* FUUUUCKK, WHAT THE FUUCK ?!!?
*snores loudly* What the fuck was that it bounced up the other guy!!?!
*groans* Alright, lets try this again with a little less suuuck
Heh
Naoo
Ehhh
See see, uh, watch.
What the problem is
I'm pressing the jump button up
It it don't go up.
I have to go out, and then up. And then maybe
that works, sometimes.
So its not-
Eh!
Now there we go, Uuuoop
*screams* AHHHHHHHHHH
GOTCHA OK NAILED IT!
Allows you to jump higher?
Is it a springy sproing?
Oooh boy, its a springy sproing!
Geauugh
Why are you- why are you not jumping?
WHY ARE YOU NOT JUMPING HIGHER?!??
Goddamnit are you kidding me?!
Stop jiggling!
JUST LET ME JUMP!
LET ME JUMP!
ooooOOOOOooo
You sack of *constipated* SHIIIT
Let me-
Are you really gonna be like that, huh?
Do I get a bounce mul-
OOOOHHH!! You-
The other guy went fine, but no! Me!  Me! I'm bad!
There we go! Ok.
I might do a few more levels and then we will get to the end of this one.
HEUUU
I made it. *guy dies painfully* Boy that was hard!
Tha' wa' harrrdd
Y'know what, aww ok
This way! NAILED IT! I got it.
I might do a few more and then we will reach the end of this video...
But this is an interesting, imaginative, concept.
NOT A GREAT CONCEPT THOUGH
I mean- I mean it's an interesting concept but, I mean like, from a moral standpoint of what's happening here
Pretty horrible.
BUT...ALAS it's a vingie(?) game.
I know what we need, I know what we need!
Heah
Hold that for me
And I put this over HeAh
And we Oooooh
NAOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
*people screams* There we go! Okay, thats the last level I'm going to try here.
So, I like this game there's an imaginative twist to it, and a really dark SINISTER twist to it.
That y'know, is REALLY DARK! And SINISTER, and that's all I have to say about that
But I've heard there is actually 135 levels, in this game.
It's a name your own price type game too
and it goes without saying
this is not reality. This is A GAME, it doesn't reflect anything in reality.
So don't take any of these themes seriously.
So I hoped you enjoyed this video!
Please try out this game, its down in the description below, and thank you everybody for watching.
And as always! I will see you, in the next video
BUH BYE!
(Whoever is reading this have a wonderful day and comment #NiceDay for everybody to see)